if a 74 year old told me when I was 14
if he told me that I gotta suck some
dick right now to be a grand master of
karate always the thing on the table
yeah I believe him
[Music]
all right this is just another one of
those weird story situations let me try
and get some of the information out and
I'll wait for Nick's weird questions let
me see a picture he always has the
weirdest question Tokyo Police on
Tuesday arrested A polyamorous 74 year
old man and one of his Ex-Wives for
allegedly brainwashing an adolescent
girl with a view to sexually assault her
dude what's up with these guys man the
dude's name Hirohito Shibuya and his
ex-wife you made that up you know roll
call no it says
what is that you never heard that no one
knows that Miss Anthony yeah my name is
Anthony yeah yeah
my name is Mike yeah I like the prince
yeah I'm on JK yeah you like to dance
[Applause]
my name is Anthony yeah I am a host yeah
I tried really hard uh-huh to do the
most
[Applause]
you know Shibuya is a city in Japan
it is
and now we're getting this the history
of field Japan
this guy Paulie Amherst does that mean
he has a lot of sex that means he has a
lot of Amber yeah what's the difference
between polyamorous and polygamy or
polyamorous and just cheating because
that's what this sounds like sounds like
he has a wife and then he groomed a
young lady no the wife helped him groom
the young ladies so remember he is 74
year old and then his ex-wife actually
her name chiaki has is 43 they've been
arrested wow yeah there's a 30 year old
different the 29 actually now that's
like Mega molester that's actually 31.
huh math okay anyways uh they were
arrested on suspicion of attempting to
commit constructive forcible sexual
intercourse a crime that takes it but it
was constructive you said yeah what the
[__] is that versus rape it says it's
it's a crime that takes advantage of a
victim when they are unconscious or in
no state to resist that sounds like
that sounds like sleep [__] yeah
that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard I'll explain what he did and then
maybe you can put a put a little bit of
a concept let me get my Paddington hat
on
by the way I watched Paddington because
everybody said Paddington was a [__] no
fire bro no I know the book I was too
old for that no it's a book it's a kids
it's not a Paddington Bear doll dude
okay what the movie that's not our
generation though no it was this I think
um it's just very childish I'm 38. no I
think the book was the book was uh but
everybody says watch pantsing because
you got to see Paddington too hi what
was the what was this I don't [__]
know I was more of like a Winnie the
Pooh kind of dude childish to me I love
yeah it's a kid's book yeah but there's
a difference like I'll watch Toy Story
three and I'll be like that's not yeah
Paddington looks wack oh dude Toy Story
three that's what I'm saying go to the
movie theater I think that John Wick 4
or Paddington you're gonna go watch
Paddington well you can't compare it
yeah I don't know if that's the exact if
you gotta do apples to apples as if he
really picked from John Wick 38 or
Paddington he's like Fast and Furious
all right so he's denied the charges
while shiaki has maintained her silence
she was arrested Tuesday in connection
with an incident that took place on
December 12th last year at his home in
Western Tokyo where he lives with his
current wife and eight of his Ex-Wives
including chiaki as well as three
children
I can't get one girlfriend to do got
nine yeah ask about him damn everybody
figure out what he's doing the
construction timers they know how to
[__] in court the ladies don't they we
call that Ridge
the genzis in Japan can't even get one
girlfriend this guy has nine wives
risked up yeah he's got more wives than
a [__] cat got lives dude that's also
bars right there dude okay Shibuya
um
so what had happened in this
constructive uh construct he and shiaki
are suspected of showing this girl
images of aliens over the course of
several hours after chiaky invited her
to their home with the promise that she
could consult a genuine fortune teller
Shibuya then told the girl
should we then tell the girl that she
would be abducted by aliens unless she
entered into a relationship with him the
girl believed him and promised to visit
him again but her family and friends
persuaded her to go to the police
why does her friends even have to tell
her yo I think this is not real no hot
take it's her fault hot takes how old
was she they just said adolescent she
seems like she has a developmental
disorder yeah I mean adolescent could be
like 10 years old let's say she's 18.
that she's a grown-ass dude let's say 18
and let's say no crime happened yeah
for the sake of conversation yeah it's
[__] her fault bro
yo to be honest though yeah even as a
dumbass 13 year old if someone told me I
better suck some dick or else an alien's
gonna come in a duck your fault you're
[__] stupid dude I ain't sucking no
dick yeah I'll let the Alien come out
the only reason why you're talking to me
is because you don't have any friends oh
[__]
you're like yo that's [__] up you know
if I'm talking to an adult an adult's
talking to me like like he's seen me at
his level yeah it's weird where's your
friends at yeah what's wrong with you
bro like aren't you why aren't you
fishing dude
if a 74 year old told me when I was 14
if he told me that I gotta suck some
dick right [__] now to be a grand
master of karate always the thing on the
table I believe him yeah what's why is
being abducted by aliens a bad thing
that's different yeah because abducted
by aliens I'll be like ah you crazy but
like if he looked like a Kung Fu Master
yeah and he looked like he knew what he
was doing and his dick looked like a
conflict I'd be like oh [__] Mr Miyagi
do I really have my mentor now oh like
if he'll only teach you Buddhist palm if
you give him a [__] yeah it's like
this because you know how Kung Fu Master
is always punching their dicks all the
time every Kung Fu Master out there I
think that's real though like the
Spartans did that I think he had to [__]
your mentor to become a warrior yeah
even the the Renaissance people did it
because they say like like we were born
in the wrong age yeah I'd be a Warrior
by now yeah suck all the [__] I'd be a
mentor
yeah so this is actually a terrible
incident because she is an adolescent
all right yeah mine was hypothetical we
don't know her yeah
some areas in Europe
Canada even think so look up the state
the age of consent in different states
to be but I think it all changed 18. it
used to be all of them did no no no no
it's marriage the age of marriage is
different for the state but uh the age
of sex is is different okay in the
majority of States AKA 34 of them it is
16 years of age in the remaining states
of age of consent is either 17 or 18
years old that's U.S
exemption even marital exemption that's
the one I was talking about some states
have that even California is 18 but I
think there's like a three-year grace
period yeah it's called statutory I
swear it's called statue you go to the
judge so it was 18 plus or minus three
no if you're 19 no if you're 19 you can
still do like 16. like oh no no that's
why they call it a statutory yeah it's
statutory grapes grapes yeah it's
statutory grape yeah I said grapes now
oh my bad I used that word earlier we'll
bleep you out yeah bleep my ass yeah
some some of those consents are pretty
low most of the states start at the age
of 16 however Arizona North Dakota
Oregon and Virginia states have minimum
age of victim as 15. why they gotta say
victim
I don't like this topic no more yeah
let's let's move on let's go back to
Shibuya yeah yeah that was fun
so this guy is he notoriously just a sex
man like he's always like you wanted to
say sex habit and then you realize how
[__] up that is huh I didn't I don't
know but then
we don't want to misuse your title yeah
I feel bad saying he had Riz because if
your go-to lines nectar yeah if your
go-to lines like you're about to get
abducted or
that's not rizz yeah it's not really how
many times do you think he's used the
abduction line on these girls oh if it
worked once he used it forever okay
let's just go too it doesn't yeah but
he's got eight wives though so that
means they all believe in aliens yeah he
must be getting them in the UFO forms
yeah or Scientology I listened to this
documentary called abducted in plain
sight it's a really good documentary
yeah it's messed up and this guy took
this he kidnapped like a family friend
and she was probably like like what like
12 or 13. oh dear Lord he like recorded
an alien voice saying if you don't have
sex with this guy in the RV the aliens
are gonna come get you or some [__] very
similar and he played it for her
isolated her made her listen to it and
then she came out and was like I guess
we have to do this and then that's how
he that's how he like did the deed with
this young woman aliens are a normal
threat so I guess it's like it's in the
vocab it's it's in with these well we're
also talking about I mean based off what
you said we're also talking about like a
12 or 13 year old mind and obviously we
some of us know really really smart 12
and 13 year olds but obvious that's also
I'm not on adults like mind you know
what I mean like very [__]
susceptible and sometimes 12 year olds
are just like oh you're an adult like
I'm gonna listen to you you probably are
speaking the truth there's some 30 year
olds that might work home dude
unfortunately there's a lot of dumb
people out here there's another
documentary on Netflix where this guy
would call random McDonald's and small I
was just thinking about that and he
would he would be like oh um you need to
research this young woman a manager at
McDonald's and they would just make them
do like all kinds no but didn't he get
one girl to suck a like an old guy's
dick like oh bro anything you can think
of oh there's drugs on her so from a
McDonald's wait but didn't he hack the
camera system too so he can watch it no
not even not even he didn't even hack it
he would just call and then he would do
this like like 900 times in in the
United States like all over mid like
small towns just for sick fun just for
like just for [__] get to the point
where somebody would do naked jumping
jacks yeah and he would that would like
he had a system I mean he got better the
more he did it too who's he trying to be
in the call a cop he pretended to be a
cop but he knew he would go to these
small towns because they would like
respect the authority and they'd be
freaked out like oh I'm not gonna
question it and then it would take one
guy to be like yo you're not a [__]
cop and then he would hang up and the
deed would be done we're in a weird
world it's crazy bro like yeah what
officer is going to tell you to suck off
your geriatric co-worker dude not even a
co-worker Beyonce of a co-worker like
you know what I'm undercover I gotta do
this
I forgot what it's called but it's like
I saw the same one don't pick up the
phone or something like the weird thing
was
I thought they got it
but maybe maybe it's just they showed us
in the documentary the camera footage
yeah yeah make blowy make [__] how
do we increase the lowest common
denominator that's what we need to do
like how do you avoid people having
single digit IQs yeah yeah how do you
that's so sad help the stupidest people
of the world that's sad we're turning
into idiocracy yeah cause dumb people
are [__] with dumb people and they've
been making more dumb people and there's
more dumb people than smart people yeah
so we're gonna have a bunch more dumb
people all of my smart friends they
start their like baby making careers
like in their 30s and they all got a
[__] IVF and [__] or they only got
like one kid when they should be having
10 kids no but only dumb people have 10
kids because they're so broke and they
start at like 10 years old except Elon
yeah that dude trying to repopulate it's
just Elon the Jews and the Mormons
that's going to be continuing this whole
like people that are having a lot of
kids that are so stupid
that's it huh
[Music]